what stands out to me is
um just just watching the republican
revenge
uh convention and this they're spewing
this
fear right like all you hear
donald trump and all of them talking
about fear
we're the ones getting killed we're the
ones getting shot
we're the ones that we're denied to live
in
certain communities we've been home
we've been shot and
all you do is keep hearing a fear
it's
it's amazing why we keep
loving this country and this country
does not love us back
and it's just
it's really so sad like i should just be
a coach
and it's so often reminded
of my color
you know it's just really sad we got to
do better
uh but we got to demand better like we
got you know it's funny
we protest and they send riot guards
right
uh they send people in riot outfits
they go to michigan with guns and
they're spinning on cops
and nothing happens the training
has to change in the police force
the unions have to be taken down in the
police force
my dad was a cop i believe
in good cops we're not trying to defund
the police and take all their money away
we're trying to get them to protect us
just like they protect everybody else
i didn't want to talk about it before
the game because it's so
hard like to just keep watching it that
video
if if you watch that video you don't
need to be black
to be outraged you don't
you need to be american and outrage
and how dare the republicans talk about
fear we're the ones
that need to be scared we're the ones
having to talk
every to every black child
what white father has to give his son a
talk
about being careful if you get pulled
over
it's it's just ridiculous and it just
keeps getting
it keeps going there's no charges
rihanna taylor no charges nothing
all we're asking is you live up to the
constitution
that's all we're asking for everybody
for everyone thank you